ERIC SEIDEL: I
think we're ready.
So I believe I'm the caboose
on this Dart summit excitement
train.
My name is Eric Seidel,
I'm here to talk to you
about Sky, which is a
experimental project going on
at the moment.
But I could talk to
you all about Sky,
I'd rather show you Sky.
So for today, I built a demo and
I published on the Android Play
Store.
It's available, Sky demo,
you can download it.
Give me a second while it
warms up on this new device.
So what you see here-- whoops.
I got to hit input two.
What you see here.
See, this is exciting
mobile live demos.
It's too bright, and it's
blown out the screen.
There we go.
Much better What you see here
doesn't look super exciting.
The exciting part is that
there is no Java drawing this.
This is drawn by Dart.
[APPLAUSE]
I'll show you the
very first demo
that we brought up in this
harness and get to the point.
This is just a square spinning,
but driving this device
at 60 Hertz from Dart.
And that is one
of the first goals
the we had for the system,
was to be fast and responsive.
We want to go way
fast 60 Hz, but that's
what this device can do.
Another demo that
we brought up early
is this touch demo, which
shows our integration
with the underlying Android,
shows pressure sensitivity,
does multi-touch
sticks to my finger
while the device
does too, et cetera.
And an even more recent
demo is this sucker.
This is all loaded down off
the network, by the way.
This is Dart code
running off the network.
Which shows us scrolling at 60
Hz, not so good on the camera.
Shows drawers.
Again, you can try
this on your own phone,
and you could feel it.
It feels much smoother than
the camera can display.
Integrated Android keyboard
including the voice keyboard,
if you're so inclined.
It's got menus,
buttons, splashes.
All the things you would
expect of a UI framework.
So that's demos.
Let's go back to the
magical video one.
Oh man.
Now I guess I get to
change my password.
So this is what we're
talking about today.
This is the Sky architecture.
So here, all the green stuff,
which sort of looks green
is Dart code.
And all the gray, or purple
as it looks on this display,
is other languages.
So here, Your UI
is written in Dart,
along with any
Dart-related business logic
that you may or may not
have, and the Sky framework.
The sky framework
and the Sky engine
are what we're going to
be talking about today.
And then we have this cross
language messaging system
which is basically Chrome's
messaging system distilled
down.
It's called Mojo.
Distilled down for doing
fast cross process,
cross language messaging to any
native APIs that are available
on the system, and any business
logic you might have in other
languages, be it C#,
Objective C, whatever you got.
So what are we doing here?
We'll Sky is here all
about providing a better
mobile experience.
A better experience for
users, a better experience
for developers.
We are here to take the
lessons many of my team
will work on the web
for over a decade.
And we're here to take the
lessons from working on the web
and try and do something
better for mobile.
Because we look around at the
current development options,
and just believe we
could do a lot better.
So what are our goals?
Well, our first
goal is performance.
When we set out to
do this, we came
from years of trying to make
the mobile web work better,
and the number one complaint
we got from developers
is it's just not fast enough.
It doesn't stick to
my user's finger,
it doesn't feel like a
mobile-expected app should
feel.
So we're here to do performance,
high performance in Sky.
We also believe in
being platform agnostic.
The previous versions
of this engine,
called Blink,
called webkit, have
been ported to every
platform under the sun.
And Sky maintains that same
level of portability in its C++
code, as well as,
of course, Dart,
which runs anywhere
that Dart VM can run.
sky offers no opinion as
to what you can or can't
do with your app.
Anything the OS lets you do,
Sky is there to help you.
Again, through those
Mojo IPC layer.
We believe that the
current development
cycles of recompile,
reinstall, reoptimize
was far superior
in web browsers.
And so we have taken a
page out of that book,
and built another edit
refresh cycle for Sky as well.
We believe in network first.
One of the powers of
web-based development
is that you can deploy
once, and all your users
have the same version
of your app right away.
Or you could do AB testing.
Things that mobile
is just getting to.
We have the URLs at the
base layer of our system.
Everywhere in our
system understands
that the network is a thing.
We also, of course, believe that
your app should looked the way
you want your app to look.
So we're here to
provide you not only
our built in powerful
layout primitives,
but also provide you the ability
to rewrite your own in whatever
you want your app to look like.
So we have, in fact, taken the
step of removing the layout
code from our C++ and
rewriting it Dart.
So if we can write
it in Dart, you
can express whatever layout
you want in Dart as well.
Same for Paint.
And of course, all
the gorgeous text
that you would
expect from something
that came from the web heritage.
All the right to left,
left to right, ligatures.
Think I'm still with you all?
Anyways, my real
point here today
is because we are such
an early stage project,
is to hear from you.
We believe that we're creating
something better for mobile,
and someone was joking with
me before this session.
They're like, well, you
could replace your session
with a Q&A about people and
what they hate about mobile.
Because that's what I'm
here to learn from you.
Is what you've had trouble
with in mobile, cause
we want to make it better.
So let's get back to the
demos, because those are fun.
And let's write ourselves
some Hello World, shall we?
So one of the things that
I tried to do for this talk
was to make Sky feel very
familiar to a Dart developer.
So to start a Sky product,
you just mkdir Hello World.
And then we all know
our lovely pub spec.
So we type a pub spec.
I've typed a couple
of these in my day.
Hello World.
Dependencies, Sky, any.
Yeah.
And then I pub
get, and that's it.
I now have everything I
need to write a Sky app,
including the stuff
to put it on Android.
It's just there on my machine.
And so now, if I want to
keep typing Dart code,
I make a lib directory,
because that's what pub likes.
Set up the Sim links.
lib/main.dart.
And I always miss a
semicolon, so we're
going to copy from our readme.
We were going to
copy from our readme.
It's fine we'll
do it on the fly.
Hello World.
My colleagues in
the back of the room
are cringing that
I forgot something.
OK and we have one more
piece that we got to type.
Wow, Chrome has
completely lost its mind.
Who works on this product?
I did for many, many years.
OK.
One more piece of boilerplate
that we need in order
to placate the Sky engine,
which comes from Chrome,
is that we need an HTML-like
file to kick it off.
So we're going to put that at
the root of our directory three
vim, main.sky.
Whoops, fix our package name.
Hello World.
And the semicolon that I
even forgot in the readme.
It's OK, we got this.
Packages, Sky.
So now, how the heck do we
get this thing on the device?
Well, again, I told you
the whole thing comes down
from pub.
So we include a little
tool called the Sky tool,
and we just type start.
And what this is
going to do is it's
going to run an HTTP
server on my machine,
serve my package
straight to my device,
and tell the device,
hey, load this thing.
So let's see if it works.
Oh.
I probably didn't
pub get enough times.
[LAUGHTER]
You think I'm kidding.
No!
Well, the phone
was not plugged in.
The man in the back
of the-- there we go.
So now we've started it up.
Can we turn on number two?
So we see it, we
see Hello World.
Except we drew Hello World
behind the status bar.
Which is probably not
what we meant to do.
But I'll tell you, this
is both good and bad.
It's good because in Sky,
you get full control.
Full control over the screen,
full control over anything
you can access in the OS.
It's bad because
you obviously don't
want to draw behind
the status board.
Or maybe not for
this example, right?
So that's where the
framework comes in.
The Sky framework helps you
know, well, oh, I'm on Android,
it has a status bar.
I guess I should indent things.
Yadda, yadda.
So let's talk about
the Sky framework.
So Sky framework.
Remember, that was this thing?
Oops, hello.
I hit number one, is that wrong?
Number four.
I'll take a projector
for number four.
OK.
We're talking about the Sky
framework, written in Dart.
That this piece of the puzzle.
So what is that piece
of the puzzle for?
Well, that piece of the puzzle
is a big bag of widgets,
to start with.
All written in Dart,
all replaceable
we're writing
through Google's what
I believe is beautiful
material design spec.
Which the Android OS
also someone follows.
The other job of
the framework is
to help guide your app
towards being jank free.
We're slowly removing
the blocking APIs
from the engine side of
things, and in the framework
we're also not
introducing blocking APIs.
So that you don't
miss those frames,
you don't block the main thread.
You are always responsive
to the user's input.
Another way that we help you
do that is by separating out
the pieces, so you do
your layout at layout
time, your paint at paint
time, you process input
at processing time.
Allows us to overlap these, it
allows us to interrupt these.
It allows us to, again, make
sure you always hit that frame.
And finally, one note
about the framework
is that it is in a functional
reactive style, which
you see also with the framework
that Casper just demoed,
and other modern frameworks that
are being experimented with.
So let's do something with
the framework, shall we?
So given how well that
first round of typing was,
I think I'm going to skip
straight to my backups.
We'll go to our-- you know
what, we can do this in Sublime.
We can go to the 21st century.
So inside my backups, I have
already typed out an example.
And the part that changed
is this main.dart file.
Sorry, now we have color.
But the big thing
the change, remember
it was just dart.sky before, so
we just imported this package
framework f in
Dart, now we import
a bit more of the framework.
We still extend our app.
You can ignore this
little style bit,
I'll talked about
that in a second.
We still have a build method.
But the new piece is that
we now have a scaffold.
And the scaffold is
the opinionated piece
of the framework that says, hey,
I'm on iOS, or I'm on Android.
I bet I have a status
bar, I shouldn't
draw there, et cetera.
It also has an action bar,
which is a material design
concept for the thing
at the top with the name
and the little, like, hot
dog for the menu, et cetera.
And here we're just
putting Hello World,
and a little text in our page.
So let's run this simple
app on our phone again.
Have to be in backup, widgets.
And we switch to
number two, and pray.
That is not right.
That is not.
That is still not.
I guess we will
try-- sorry, folks.
I have caused something
to be confused.
I need the man in the
back of the room again.
Or maybe this is why you
don't do mobile live demos.
You know, when it doesn't
work on one phone,
you take one of the
other three phones
that you brought
forward with you.
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC SEIDEL: You know, I only
have the one terminal open,
so I would think not.
But anything is possible.
Ta-da!
It was just the phone.
Oh, sorry.
It looks green to me.
So well, moving
to that phone has
made the rest of this a
little more complicated.
So you know what, we're
actually going to move back,
and then I'm going to
show you the next feature.
Which is the fact, you
know that I talked before
about how silly was this
compile, install, optimize
cycle, and then you
see me doing it, right?
I come back to my
terminal every time.
It's silly.
So I don't want to do that.
And so I'm going
to just reinstall.
Remember I told you that
everything came along with?
Everything really
does come along with.
Well, I'm giving
up on that phone.
Sorry.
We're going back,
we're going to go
a different part of the demo.
So the next thing I was going to
show you is that I could shake
to reload, but since
I'm on a tablet,
this thing doesn't
have an accelerometer,
and it cannot shake to reload.
So I will show you
how to do that,
but you're going to
have to try it yourself.
Because, again, always
on the place where
you can play with it yourself.
The one piece of this widget's
one demo that I didn't show you
was in this main.sky,
I added an import here
which imports another
piece of the framework that
loads another small
piece of Dart code.
Which, again, we can see,
because it's in the framework.
And this little
piece of Dart code
listens to an Android sensor.
And when the sensor changes, it
decides whether you're shaking
or not.
And then issues a
reload on the screen.
Now, how exactly talks
to the Android center
is a detailed better
covered in our readmes.
Because the way that
this uses, it that mojo
IPC system that I was
talking about before.
And this is 40
lines of code here,
it's another 20 lines
of code in the mojom
to specify how it wants
to talk to the API.
And then some other
40 lines of Java.
Mostly to parrot what the
Android system says back
to the mojom.
So it's a very small amount
of code to expose the Android
sensors, but this is how
we do shake to reload,
which unfortunately I cannot
demo because the tablet
doesn't support it.
So the last and final
thing that I want to demo,
since my demos are
having so much luck,
is I want to demo a slightly
more complicated use
of this framework.
Because right now,
all we've done
is we've drawn some pretty
text on the screen, right?
We could do something a
little more interactive.
So we're going to back
up and go to widgets2.
And we'll load this sucker
up, and I'll switch screens.
You know, I'm going to be a pro
at pushing these buttons here
pretty soon.
I'm going to be a pro,
especially if it actually
works.
You know, I don't
know what to tell you.
Now the [INAUDIBLE] listener
is some other silliness.
I don't know what to tell you.
This is what doing demos
live on stage with mobile
is going to get you.
But I'm going to
show you instead.
So what we were
going to do is we
were going to build a button.
And so if you look down
at our build method,
before we just had this
scaffold and this action bar.
Here we were adding another
container and the content,
and we're adding two
buttons and event
listeners around each button.
And these event listeners
listen to the pointer up,
and they call this say
method that we defined above
to say hello, or say goodbye.
And the say method,
what it does is
it's mostly just a setter
for this greeting variable
that we have.
But it also calls
the set state, which
lets the underlying
framework know, hey,
I'm changing my state
in my data model.
You better ask me again
if you want to display.
And so before the next frame
comes up, it called built.
So I can try sending
it one more time,
but this is why you're not
shipping things on Sky today.
And we'll have better
demos next time.
Anyways, before were completely
done with the demo section,
I do want to talk a
little bit about tooling.
Because one of the
things that we learned
in our very long time
while working on the web
is if you want to make
the darn thing fast,
you need to have tools
to understand how.
And so thankfully, we built
lots of tools in those years.
And because we come
from that world,
we have brought
forward those tools.
And so I wanted to
show you one of these.
So if we say pull up our good
old spinning square again, yep.
I'll switch to the
screen just second.
If we pull up our
spring square again,
you know what the spinning
square looks like.
But I want to actually
prove to myself,
is that hitting every frame?
Well, I can tell you.
If we go back to
our little screen.
We go to this, and
we do start_tracing.
And now it's tracing
on the device.
If I do stop_tracing, it
downloads the little trace.
And if we go back
to our web browser,
and we go to about:tracing,
and we click load.
So this is Chrome's
about:tracing functionality,
which is used for
understanding web pages.
But we also wired
up the Sky engine
to be able to spit out
compatible trace files.
So when we go to the
Sky trace, and huzzah!
You see a lot of lines.
The interesting part, so
those little orange lines,
which you may not be able
to see very well, these.
Those are the v-syncs.
And you can see from
this area is just empty.
We are doing the entire
work of rendering
that frame in 1.2 milliseconds.
Obviously we're not
rendering very much.
But the idea is
that we have tons
of space on the simple example.
We could show you
slightly more complicated,
which would also
have tons of space,
and you could dive into
this on your own time.
But the idea here is that we
have the tools to understand,
and you have the
tools to understand
how to make your apps fast.
So let's go back and
I want to show you
one more tool, which should be
very familiar to this crowd.
Which is, not only do we
get all the Chrome tools,
but we get all the Dart tools.
And so as of this
last weekend, it
is now possible also
with the spinning square
to, if I just forward one little
port, the Observatory port,
I just forwarded the
port-- oh, hello.
Co-host.
I just forwarded the port
from the device to my machine.
I am now connecting
to Observatory
on the device from my laptop.
And so I can click.
[APPLAUSE]
I can click on the
spinning square.
And honestly, I'm not a super
amazing Observatory guru yet.
Because it just
came online for us.
But I can set a break point.
And if I go back to my screen,
I've stopped the square.
So I can now go back to my other
screen, and we can go, whoops.
We can go back to this
one, to the debugger.
And I can hit See
a couple times,
and I can see the squares
turning, you can't.
But well, I'll show
you that in a second.
I can also do things like
p square, style, background
color.
This part's all going away.
We're rewriting the
style system as we speak.
Orange, and then
remove my-- well,
I don't need to
remove my break point,
but I can just to continue.
Ta-da!
In any case,
Observatory doesn't work
on the one that's
on the Play Store,
but the next version
I push, it will.
Because that came in 11th
hour for this conference.
But you can see, you
get the Chrome tools,
you get the Dart tools.
It's paradise, right?
Anyways, that's most of what
I wanted to tell you today.
I want to thank you
all-- oh, screen.
all for listening.
Again, we're super early stage.
My goal here is, again,
to solicit your feedback.
So I brought my entire team,
they're sitting in the back.
And we will gladly
field your questions.
Please come talk to us.
Or if you're watching us on
YouTube, please reach out.
There's our GitHub URL,
there's our mailing list.
Thank you very much.
MALE SPEAKER: If you'd like
to do a couple of questions,
you've got a few minutes.
ERIC SEIDEL: OK.
I have time for some
questions, if anybody has any.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER 2: Hey, Kevin!
Give him the microphone.
MALE SPEAKER: What?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Question
is, are you exposing
all the OpenGL calls to Dart?
ERIC SEIDEL: So we have
currently removed the WebGL
wrapper that you might have
expected from a browser,
so we don't have WebGL.
One could expose, if there's
a Dart library on pub already
that does GL, we could
certainly implement that.
But I think that
there's a question
that I have to ask myself
is, if I want to write WebGL,
where do I want to write it?
In this system, I don't
need to write it in Dart,
I don't need to write it in Sky.
I could take my
existing C++ to OpenGL.
So I guess the short
answer to your question
is, we don't currently, we could
if that's important to you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
Sure.
If somebody's written
a [INAUDIBLE] API
bindings for Dart, we certainly
could expose those, yes.
We aren't today.
MALE SPEAKER: Got time
for maybe one more.
AUDIENCE: How is
Sky work in iOS?
ERIC SEIDEL: So Sky
doesn't today work in iOS.
But the engine
itself is portable,
and the VM is portable, as you
heard Casper talking about.
So the constraints are
different in that ecosystem.
There are some-- you sign
different agreements to play
on that phone.
Based on those agreements that
you may or may not signed,
the technology choices may need
to be slightly differently,
but we will cross those bridges.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
ERIC SEIDEL: Thank you.